do when I when I I've only been a
private jet a few times and when I was
with the creators of Game of Thrones I
wasn't wearing my seat belt and the guy
goes big guy who's put your seat belt on
who gives a [ __ ] man I never in my sleep
on planes yells I'm these small planes
you shoot he goes last time we're going
he said they were going somewhere in
Ireland on a private jet and they hit a
bumping it's almost Brooklyn that's
right
yours I went up and hit the last thing I
put here he goes if we I would've told
you I would have broke my neck yes she
was people it happens all the time all
the time dogs my dog I had my dog on the
plane
me and my dad suzune and like that my
dog [ __ ] hit the top of that claim it
was bad I had to hold my dog [ __ ] up
my pit bull right in the back my father
always said to keep you see both lanes
are crazy
yeah you hit wind shears you hit wind
pockets you hit like a it's just I'm
like whoa today's a good bad it'll feel
good with planes either
we have done traveling a bunch on
Thursday the air I just feel like [ __ ]
ya know here are the people you're
sniffing everyone's farts oh yeah
morning yes there's not any flooring
how's the food not better at this point
you've only five first class the food
I'm like myself a plastic rabbit or I'll
kill you to have good food we're gonna
kill you the back in the day they used
to cook food right there they do rack of
lamb first class back in the day on Pan
Am and masculine dude they would cook
you the stewardesses would come out and
they would cook broad in ovens when you
fly international some sometimes the the
strike up those homemade cookies they
come around with hot fresh-baked cookies
to everybody and a wine light I will fly
whatever you want and I'm [ __ ] they're
delicious
yeah I had to in it's rare I do this but
when I'm on tour to flux on my diet they
gave me one I went this might be the
best cook ever had came back with excuse
me do you Pam do you have any more
cookies she's like yes we do I'm I had
to hit her up I was embarrassed about it
can I get a few more cool my mom
embarrass the [ __ ] out of me because my
mom and I are sitting coach right behind
first class and
they handed out soft juicy chocolate
chip cookies smell and coach how good
does this my mother said excuse me are
there cookies back here for us and the
woman said no that's just for a first
class use that's bad manners I can smell
them and it's tempting me I'm making my
mouth water and that's bad manners
awfully good that's bad manners on
Stewarts killed [ __ ] yeah well I'm
sorry to pay for first class right like
please don't say that that's super like
weird to do that it's funny though
that's bad manners like they don't you
find a boy still hey they was wafting
into all our nostril the reason why I
say you see 2:17 was the biggest UFC the
best of all time is because the current
layout of the land where it's been the
worst year of UFC ever the numbers are
down the promotion's awful the social
medias terrible they've sold Ronda's out
Brock's out Conners being gone there's
all this stuff people are hating on it
there's all sorts of [ __ ] going on and
the the the kind of flex their muscle
Ike whoa whoa ho-ho
hold the [ __ ] up we're still the UFC
here I know everyone thinks that this
we're the Titanic and the ship is
sailing or sinking no no we're still did
you [ __ ] FC relax it's all good
we can we still got it
and when you get cards like these it
reminds you of Oh Mike there it is man
that's why we love it there it is to
being caught so caught up in the Floyd
Connor stuff you know and that's that's
not what makes this sport special or we
get so caught up in he said she said and
who's a draw on this a draw and then you
get this beauty of a card and it's like
oh yeah yeah we're good we're good
we need this one good god did we need
this one there's a great there's a you
don't you know is a beautiful night yeah
straight up angry best-case scenario you
couldn't write a card like this
it's exactly what they needed exactly
what's the most that somebody's asked
you to borrow in that you lent them you
know have to name their name but that
you honestly did the most I asked to
borrow or that you've asked a borrower
or someone has asked you to borrow for
me I think it's just about maybe 400
bucks I think dollars right Brian you've
been in more issues if you're an adult
I've lent some some I let a friend of
mine $16,000
do you ever pay back no no I didn't
expect it to I gave it to him I said
this is this is this is not money I'm
gonna see you back but I didn't do it
because he just really needed it yeah
and I have no regrets about it I was
gonna buy this house that was just at
the time I clearly out of my price range
maybe it helped with the down payment
and my friend at the time was like I'll
just do it and then you just pay me back
we'll have a monthly plan and then once
it came down to it I didn't pull the
trigger I'm like no if I can't get the
house myself it's gonna cheap in this I
didn't do it but he was down Wow super
surprised and it's cool yeah super cool
borrowing money that's uh that's weird
man yeah give it away later just yeah if
you get it back to me you can get it
back to me but yeah that cuz then you
have a real friend like if it's a real
friend and they really need it or
something that is up and you can do it
like you know it's you you just have to
have that choice a lot of times you're
enabling them though right where they're
fuck-ups and then they're like oh can I
get 10 G's I'll pay it back yeah and you
know you're just extending the time of
being a fuckton right yeah right because
other people if they need that money
they have means of the hard work in
other ways to go about getting it sure
where it's gonna be substantial work
like if you were if you if you wanted to
start a business say I'd be like and you
hadn't wanted to borrow me about hey I
bet I would lend it to you cuz I would
go yeah the chance of you paying me back
are very high also you know you see him
all the time in here and then I'm afraid
up down I shake him down and you could
have the audience get angry at him you
have you have well BIOS me 16 grand from
Beth from mixed martial arts fights but
that's why do you suppose get at at a
little more
sixteen right